it is January 15 2023 and you're
watching the code report the highly
anticipated state of JavaScript survey
results are in which can make or break
the life of a JavaScript framework you
are not
this year it had nearly 40 000 responses
compared to just 15 000 last year and
let me tell you the results are
completely and utterly shocking because
that will improve retention on this
video for demographics we mostly have
developers over the age of 25 with at
least three years of experience the
majority of responses come from the
United States and Europe and what's kind
of surprising is that only three percent
make more than 200k a year and over 60
percent make less than 100K a year the
United States is by far the most well
paid region with Nigeria down at the
bottom if you want to make more money
try to be born in the right country when
it comes to gender Juggalos have a
slight Advantage but juggalettes are not
far behind and non-binary genders have
the highest percentage above 100K but
this might be a disappointing reality
check going from a three-month
JavaScript boot camp to the lambo
dealership is not as easy as they make
it sound now when it comes to actual
JavaScript features knowledge coalescing
seems to be the most popular new feature
it's a great feature but I was surprised
at how many people are not tapping
logical ass a feature I use all the time
where you can assign a variable only
when it's not already defined but the
real reason we all take this survey is
to Hype up the JavaScript Frameworks we
love and [ __ ] on all the ones we hate
the team behind the survey has done a
spectacular job visualizing this data
here we have a tier list where libraries
are ranked based on the percentage of
users that would use them again at the
top I'm glad to see many of the
Technologies in my own stack like spell
typescript playwright and V and nexjs
made the cut here as well now one thing
that surprised me was that react came in
higher than Vue they're only separated
by about six percent but I would have
expected view to be higher than react in
general the older and more established a
technology is the more people tend to
hate it as we can see here with angular
down at the bottom in my opinion angular
doesn't really get a fair representation
on the survey it's been portrayed as the
arch nemesis to react and a lot of
people out there just love to hate it
even if they've never tried it it's done
some awesome things over the last few
years and its score is improving I
project it to be the most popular
framework work by the year 2086 also on
the Bottom Rung we have tools like Gulp
and browserify which have been on the
decline for a very long time most hated
of all though is Cordova as you know I
don't like to say bad things about other
Technologies but if you want to build a
mobile app with Cordova today you'll
have to navigate through a dumpster fire
of unmaintained plugins another surprise
is Gatsby being so low which used to be
an extremely popular react meta
framework it's been on a free fall from
88 satisfaction all the way down to 38
and finally here at the bottom we have
learned which was abandoned for a little
while but is now managed by NX one thing
to keep in mind with this tier list is
that a low ranking shouldn't discourage
you from using a technology find the
right tool for the job because
everything here in the top tier will
likely be replaced when the hype train
rolls in next year the tier only
includes Tech used by 10 percent of
people and there's a bunch of up and
coming tools like Astro quick and solid
that will likely disrupt this tier by
next year in addition to Frameworks I
think there's a few libraries you should
keep your eye on in 2023 I've been
playing with tan stack query trpc and
Zod and another interesting thing on
this survey is that front and developers
now use typescript more than vanilla
JavaScript this was Unthinkable a few
years ago but something I predicted
multiple times because once you go
typescript you never go back and that
brings us to the final Revelation under
video creators fireship was ranked
number one I have no idea how we got to
this point but I'm extremely grateful
and you made my mom very proud this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one